[Music]
okay we have like 13 more minutes to
begin yeah I know you can see me but let
me know if you can hear me okay very
nice
okay so this here next to me you see
this chess set this is the winner's
prize and in this box you will get your
questions one at a time so when when you
see the question you just write the
answer in the chat and I have this C
notebook here and I will write you down
and a word you one point so after 60
questions those of you with the most
points will be the winners and will be
awarded this nice chess set so that's
about it no I do not count them as world
champions but it doesn't really matter
as none of the questions so will be
about them matter is somewhere around
here he's running around the entire day
now I tried to make all the questions as
clear as possible so flying fox what
options are you talking about
there will be no options for you to
choose from if that's what you're
referring to there will be just a
question and you will write an answer I
try to make sure that the answer will be
one word two maybe two words I don't
think I've put more than two words in
any no there won't be a multi choice
there are a couple of questions where
you will have to finish the sentence
though
well like I said if you type Fisher with
two R's I maybe I could you know allow
that but if you really misspelled it
then I'm afraid I will have to look for
another correct answer so you know you
have to type fast although try to try to
type as correct as possible although I
will know if you're if you know the
answer or you're just trying to do
something no there will not be multiple
choice questions like I said you will
have to give the answer or you will have
to finish the sentence although most of
the questions well you can answer many
times although I don't think what's the
point if you miss the first time someone
else will be you can't hear me anymore
are you sure because my microphone is
the registering as yeah I think there's
something wrong with your speakers man
now the questions aren't hard at all
they're like I mean if you're if you're
interested in chess and if you follow
the chests on the internet I'm pretty
sure you'll be able what programs do I
use the audio is not okay what's wrong
with the audio
well the audio doesn't really matter I
will show you the question here where
this chessboard is so I mean I will read
the question but you don't have to wait
for me to to read it
well I don't know if it's good to listen
to music and play chess simultaneously
although if you watch Eric Hanson
strings then you know what one could say
that it is and for the program's I use a
well I only use ops you know the open
broadcasting software I use it for
streaming and for recording likewise and
if I analyze a game I use chess comms
analysis board
yeah well I like I said I like a good
quiz and I haven't seen any live quizzes
although that that's also a nice
question is quizzes a plural of quiz so
it's hard to say we are starting in
exactly nine minutes so in my time zone
it's 851 at 8:52 p.m. so 9:00 p.m. will
be in exactly 8 minutes
now it's okay yeah yeah next time the
prize will be a chess clock no worries
yeah like Pedro said you don't need to
listen to anything I say when we are
ready for the question no English is not
my first language my first language is
Croatian well from Croatia
I don't think motto is from Croatia I
think motto is from Bosnia but that's
like a country right next to Croatia so
no not Zagreb Zagreb is the capital and
from town like 60 kilometers from Zagreb
in courage at sea thanks Nico who are
you from well a lot of people asked me
how will I send the chess board to
Madagascar or how will I send the chess
board to India well I probably won't
send it I will probably just buy a chess
set in India and send it from India to
that address in India so I think that's
that's the easiest way to do it
thanks.thanks up block well over yeah of
course I want to come to India I don't
really have a chance to do so at the
moment but you know you never know
no I didn't get a sponsor yet I've sent
a couple of emails but today haven't
returned any of them but since this is
the first quiz maybe maybe in a couple
of more quizzes yeah Oh mug is nice I've
been to mug well it took me like two
months to get from four point five K to
5k subscribers so yeah I'm very
surprised that I got almost seven point
five K now a couple of in a couple of
days no I don't teach chess well I do
teach chess to anyone who is interested
in learning chess although here where I
live not a lot of people are interested
in it yes 10k is a very nice milestone
why am i giving prizes like this just
blades
well since people are watching my videos
I do get some sort of revenue from
YouTube and I did make some money out of
YouTube this month and so some some of
that money I used to buy this chess set
to give as a reward for reaching this
5000 subscribers milestone
well I could we I could make a video
what it takes to become master or Grand
Master but since I'm not a master or a
Grand Master you know I could I couldn't
speak from personal experience about it
yeah I started with the top ten series
and was thinking about doing it every
week but you know it takes a lot of time
to make those videos how much money I
got well this week this last month I got
around I think it was $400 yeah Croatia
is the land of serious Sam it was I
think the first the first first-person
shooter
made in Croatia my chess rating is 2070
so I'm I'm hoping I can break here 2100
by the end of the year maybe
yeah I mean whenever I want leeches I
try to play as many people although I
usually play only bulletin hyper bullet
tournaments if someone challenges me I
almost always accept yeah well there are
people who analyze a lot more in their
videos but I just try to analyze the
moves that I don't find the most
interesting yeah and here it's 857 so I
think another two and a half minutes I
don't want to start before that because
well I announced it for 9 p.m. and I did
set a timer for the quiz
okay so the quiz will start in about one
minute
so I hope none of you will spam in the
chat because you know I do have to keep
tracking the chat who will answer first
and well that's about that's about it
Aya's are always watching very nice
well it's hard to say what you should
buy for a first chess book but I I
seriously consider that you should study
endgame when you begin learning chess
yeah very nice set by Brian code of
honor people okay so as soon as you see
the question you're free to answer you
don't have to wait for me to read the
question and it's almost time I hope the
stream is doing fine
it's not time yet it's too late oh and
it's it's 9:00 p.m. so I hope you're
ready for the first question here we go
so question number one
okay Tom Smith answered correctly so Tom
Smith you get a point I've written you
down in my book okay
yes yes it's porn
although Tom Smith did answer first
yes yes it's upon okay so I I think it
will be around one minute for one
question but like I said if someone
answers before that we can go to the
second question so here goes the second
question
but in all skirt answers first yes yes
he's from Norway although button Oscar
did answer first and we also have Sweden
and Denmark very nice congratulations
but in Oscar for entering first well I'm
sure that you may have been first in
your chat but I have to consider my chat
so he who was first will be first in my
chat yeah I don't have to check again
although I will
so it's button Oh squirt he is the first
person to answer Norway Tom Schmitt is
the second person to answer Norway so
let's see the third question
now we'll see who really knows his chest
and Tom Smith gets another correct
answer for answering Paul Morphy very
nice Tom Smith so this is your second
correct answer yes yes it was Paul
Morphy congratulations to Tom Schmidt
for answering first
okay guys onto the fourth question I
hope you're ready
and Gerardo Mia answers first yes yes it
was Gary Kasparov and Gerardo Maia
answered first guys so Gerardo Mia gets
a plus in my book it's very nice
well Tull was but Gary Kasparov broke
that record so 60 questions in total
let's go to the next question
well I can't tell you at what age
because that could maybe be one of the
questions so let's go to question number
five
and button all squirt answers first will
hem steinitz and that is the correct
answer so button Oh squirt gets another
plus in my book yes some do consider
more free the first champion but the
first official world champion was
William Chinese very nice guys very nice
I see all of you know your chests
although button Oh squirt was first so
let's see question number six hope you
ready now we'll see who really knows he
is chess history
and Gerardo Mia answers first the
correct answer is Emanuel ask her guys
Emanuel asked her held the world title
for 27 years and that is the record in
holding the world championship title
very nice I see a lot of correct answers
but like I said he who types first wins
let's go for question number 7 are you
ready here it is let's dive into that
history a bit more
well sub answered first he he typed
Kappa but we all know who Kappa is so
sub gets a plus in my book
congratulations
the sub yes it was host josé raúl
capablanca very nice up I will allow it
since there is no other chess player
that could be considered
Kappa ready for question number 8 and I
hope all of you are as well
and this is a tricky one so be careful
what you type
Tom Smith answered second with 64 but
sub was first with 32 and of course yes
and we even have a 36 and we even have
an 18 and a 33 but very nice sub was
first and sub gets a plus in my book so
now we actually have a tie four people
have two correct answers and moving on
to question number nine hope you're
ready
so here's question number nine also
could be a tricky one so be careful
before you type okay very nice answers
guys and Tom Smith was first so Tom
Smith gets a plus in my book and we have
all sorts of answers two three four one
yeah but in Oscar to our second very
very close I I already see this could be
a tight battle between the four of you
although some some some of them may
still catch up you never know yes the
answer is two moves with black eye I do
feel you're unfortunate if you're
lagging but can I can't really do
anything about this okay ready for
question number ten guys let's see it
Tom Smith answers first with a knight
then Brandon button then the rest of you
yes yes it's a night you guys you have
you have to be quicker if you want to
beat down Tom is the Tom seems to be a
beast if any of you will be interested
if I'm following the chat correctly I
will copy paste the entire chat and you
will be able to download it from this
video so you will see that everything is
correct yeah
here with the best Bing wins okay
ready for question number 11
and again Tom Smith first followed by
Botti no skirt the correct answer is of
course c5 and we don't have a lot of
ephors efore is not a Sicilian defense
guys before is a King's pawn opening you
have to the black side place the Cillian
defense
I assure you what in Oscar Thomas first
so moving on to question number 12
and Tom Smith answers first again so
here is a plus for Tom Smith
like I said Gerardo I will put the
entire chat so you can download it and
you will be free to check it the answer
was the Italian game and Tom Smith
answered first so moving on to question
number 13 now is now we'll see who
really knows his chess history this is a
this is a big one
and Brian Brian answered first so
congratulations to Brian this is his
first point very nice well at least in
this question Tom didn't you know go
through with his first Google Fiber okay
so let's see question number 14 and this
is a very tricky one yes I see
everyone's comments gf TV
well Tom answer the L but I cannot
accept L I have to go with Ella kind
which was subs answer so simply L will
not do yes only Alexander Alekhine
held the title until his death and then
well there was a big tournament with
three Soviet players and well what
Finnick one that easily sorry Tom I
can't accept l that's a bit a bit too
short now Tom is not a cheater Tom
really knows his chest but this question
I cannot accept l l could be anyone
weird al' yankovic okay so moving on to
question number 15 and guys please
without the without the spam so I can
follow the chat if you will okay so
let's see who can answer question number
15
and Brian answers correctly first Brian
Tangerang Galilee of course it's the
dark square bishop after you finish
arrow the guy tom did answer first but
he answered the knight so the plus goes
to Brian no not the light bishop the
dark square bishop well a lot of you are
saying that you were first I'm sure you
were first on your PC but I don't know
it might be due to your latency or pain
okay let's go to question number 16 now
he who knows this I will truly have
respect for him
and Brian answered first guys yes yes
the answer is petrosyan Tigran Burton
which petrosyan no no if you remember it
Petrosyan took the title from Botvinnik
after what winning defended his title
against Michael Thailand vasily smyslov
and then boris receive its passkey
well he took the title from petrosyan
and it's a very nice I'm glad you know
all the answers that's I commend you but
Brian was first so let's go to question
number 17 and this is also a very tricky
one so so be careful on this one ok I
see a lot of answers everybody knows
it's 9
although Tom Smith did answer first
congratulations to Tom Smith and we even
have an 8 but the answer is 9 since you
have one Queen and you have eight points
you know each of those bones can be
promoted to a queen so that's nine
Queens not 18 each player each player
can have 9 okay moving on question
number 18 now let's see who knows this
one
this one goes to a Peter varme Peter
Peter Varma congratulations this is your
first correct answer yes yes it's a
stalemate very nice
I see all of you know yes better it is
the draw let's go to question number 19
I'll do Nullah album full and I'll
answers first it was in 1985 and
congratulations Adam this is your first
correct answer so you get a plus in my
book and yes we have a lot of different
questions here but still it was 1985
yeah all sorts of years okay
ready for question number 20 this is a
bit harder but you know so it won't be
just a who types faster competition
and dietra answers first it was the
first correct answer that I will admit
it was in Reykjavik a lot of you are
saying Iceland but Iceland is not a city
Reykjavik is a city in Iceland yeah so
Deidre you get a plus in my book moving
on to question number 20 okay guys this
is why I didn't tell you when you asked
me about Michal towel so let's see which
or you know this one
and Ryan answers first Mikkel tal was 23
years old so congratulations to Brian he
was 23 years old and then casparo broke
that record and became world champion
with at 22 years of age so very nice
Brian yes yes it's 22 no 22 was Garrick
as part of 23 is Michael tall
so moving on question number 22 okay I'm
pretty sure any of you who have internet
will be able to answer this one
and algún answers first
of course it's magnus carlsen well how
do most of you not know who the Mozart
of chess is no they call the commanders
calls on the Mozart of chess I agree a
lot of other players deserve this title
as well but score check Oh
we'll do a score check don't you worry
about the score on keeping score very
nicely so moving on to question number
23
okay I will give it to Brian it's the
correct answer Yvonne truck very nice
Brian you were missing that last letter
K but I will I will allow it I can see
you know that it's him
yes big Jackie also known as vasilyev on
Chuck the Beast okay so moving on Iran
Chuck is not the master of drawing
Yvonne should be defeated Carlsen twice
twice in in one championship so I'm
really sorry about the Joseph but I
can't I can do anything if you're if you
have a bad thing if you play any game
with a bad ping
I mean you will suffer but I can see
that this could be an issue for people
with well with bigger things so I will
try to I will try to do it differently
next time but for now it is as it is yes
I will upload the chat don't worry okay
question number 24
and Alden answers first so
congratulations algún this is your third
correct answer is it is of course the
Beast of Baku yes yes it's garry
kasparov
very nice okay guys moving on to the
next question so question number 25
yeah button I will try to arrange it
some other way but for now it is as it
is okay I'm pretty sure all of you know
the next question so you know try to
type quickly I will give it to button
very nice button no skirt it is Sergei
Sergei Kuryakin yes very nice Wesley so
it's it wasn't Wesley so nor Anand Anand
hasn't challenged anyone for the title
since well since he lost it to Magnus
Carlsen so very nice
even with your a huge pink button you
still managed to answer first so see it
can be done
and moving on to question number 26
yes sir nice as you all know this one
but Tom Smith is first
yes it's wishy we saw at an island
very nice guys yeah yes well I basically
did because they tricked me so let's see
question number 27 this one you have to
you have to finish the sentence so let's
see who will be able to solve this one
yes Tom Smith you are correct and once
again you are first so a move in which
the king and rook are moved
simultaneously it's called a castle or
castling that would have allowed both
very nice I see all of you know this so
let's see question number 28
yeah okay I didn't know how many people
would show up so I didn't know how hard
I should make the questions and the
button or squirt answers first and yes
of course it is the king
so very nice button got an art it says
rook that's that's quite an answer very
nice body no squirt so let's see
question number 29
you don't have okay I will say after
this one yes it's the Queen Tom Smith
did answer first
I assure you guys I am completely aware
of the chat and I can see who wrote the
first answer it's not at all a problem
although if you have a big if you had a
large ping then it will seem like you've
answer first but in reality you haven't
it's only due to your ping you will
receive the other guys answer after you
have received yours but since I am
hosting this chat
I am seeing who was first and that is
definitely okay so let's move on to
question number 30
okay and for this one you have to really
really write the full name
and algún answers first yes it is Robert
James Fisher so congratulations to algún
very nice yes yes it is Robert James if
you've seen the movie the pawn sacrifice
which Dobby McGuire maybe you remember
the scene from the game with Boris
Spassky where Spassky tells him you're
not looking well
Robert James although I think it was a
very lousy movie ok so moving on to
question number 31 and if any of you
know this one well you will still get
one point but it should really be worth
like maybe 20 points
and yes we have a real a real scholar
here Brian answers first
although sub was second and we have a
lot of answers who know this but Brian
gets a plus in my book so yeah pawn
sacrifice is the movie and it's a it's a
very interesting story how from say from
the front one hundred Anakin got his
nickname Philidor but I will save that
for some of my videos in the in in pawn
sacrifice with Tobey Maguire in the last
scene a nickel I will not stay quiet
answered second and third because only
the one who answered first to get the
point but like I said I will I will make
the chat public so you can check if you
want to if all the questions were
correct yeah I was thinking about making
the questions a bit harder but I don't
know okay for for next quiz I will have
more information how to make it okay
question number 32 you've pretty much
answered this one but still I think you
have to think a bit
okay Tom Smith first with Alden Alden
then CJ Monty
so Tom Smith you get a plus in my book
yes it was Mikkel tau at the age of 23
very nice yes
Murphy perhaps but Morphy was never an
official world champion he was just
considered the strongest player in the
world yes yes it was tall
so moving on question number 33 and we
have yours out of here very nice now
yours are we'll take the points from
everyone okay now let's see who knows
this one some real chess history here
Tom Smith is first then out on then
Brian then baton Oh squirt so Tom Smith
gets a plus Yozora visa is a beast
player on leeches you should definitely
check him out and challenge you into a
game you'll be quite surprised
now deeper blue is not the correct
deeper blue is not the correct name
because well the first computer Kasparov
played was a deep thought and then the
other computer he played in 1996 was
deep blue although they just called it
the deeper blue but deep blue is the
correct answer
so let's go
question number 34
even deep throat
yes Tom Smith I will allow it button was
second but Tom Smith was first yes it's
the is the former Filipino
representative Wesley so currently
playing for the United States second
boer second board although maybe his
playing first board now I'm not really
sure well even if it's not you should be
playing first board yes yes it is Wesley
so okay moving on question number 35
okay to answer the next question you
have to really know your chess Tom is
first out on the second and Brian is
third yes it is
onigiri the draw master
yeah Oh Rochelle Sookie well Reshevsky
was an artist but not the one we're
looking for
for this question yes I think after this
dream Tom Smith will be known as the the
guy with the greatest internet in the
world probably okay let's go
question number 36 who knows this one
yeah it surely feels like 67 thousand
okay you can't answer you way every part
tight pal
parth touch pal I'm not sure if it's
pronounced like that but you sir
have answered correctly and you have
answered first and it was Viswanathan
Anand because you know when he was
younger he played like extremely fast
like like no other player ever like that
maybe kappa blanka but that's a
different story
but yeah it was definitely the whoosh
Anand
so moving on let's go to question number
37 some more nice history
and Brian answers first and second is
button but Brian gets plus and it yes it
was Mikhail Botvinnik they're nice well
yes I did enter it at some point but
this just shows if you're following
what's going on and if you're listening
so it's fair for everyone no button
don't give up you're doing so well
so let's go to question number 38
now we'll see who knows his history tom
is first for now and Tom is first brian
is second
alden is third so tom gets a plus in my
book and yes it is Robert James Fisher
in 1975 he refused to play against
Karpov and Karpov was declared the
winner
interesting story Karpov was playing
tennis when they told him that Fischer
would not play so when Karpov found out
that he became world champion he just
continued his tennis match with a friend
yeah ii should get half point well that
is somewhat interesting but i would have
to have more people here in this quiz
you know to follow everything so you
have to be first and tom is doing very
well ah don't should play against Brian
okay so let's try a question number 39
now I'm still not you away maybe one of
the questions will be no it's not James
Gordon
that's Fisher no one who knows morph is
middle name well I don't believe this
and naga ky naga KY answers first and
the correct answer is charles so yeah
the pride and sorrow of chess middle
name is Paul Charles Murphy very nice
okay so I see what kind of questions I
have to ask so it wouldn't be a
competition of who has the faster
internet well not really
if you if you ever read anything about
Murphy you know Charles will stick there
okay but again congratulations to nagas
for his first plus a very nice job
question number 40
yes yes Tom Smith I will allow it thus
candy as short for Scandinavian yes yes
no it's not the Slav or the King pawn or
the Danish or the center country
although it might be called the center
counter but it's the Scandinavian but a
lot of different questions here I like
it very nice ok let's go to question
number 41
John Bartholomew I like that okay it's
Tom Smith then Alden then Brian the
correct answer is garry kasparov
from baku azerbaijan yes the Beast is
coming out of retirement to play the st.
Louis rabid and blitz back we see in
Azerbaijan let's see question number 42
ok Vanaja Gangi that's a that's a pretty
ugly accusation to make since I have no
idea idea who tom is and I assure you no
one knows the questions except me even I
don't really remember them since I wrote
them all today yeah it will be great to
see Matt st. Louis so let's go to
question number 42 okay now you have to
either really know your history or you
have to be watching my videos to know
the answer to the next question
Nagesh KY is the first correct answer
that I will allow branded answer first
but he wrote further kana and I I can't
allow that since if it was just Marshall
I would allow it but yeah it's Frank
Marshall the guy that held the title of
the strongest player in the United
States for almost 30 years you might
know him from his Marshall attack a
variation of the rule opus but even more
you should know him for this beautiful
game called the American Beauty Sarah
Vaughn no it is not Sarah one okay let's
go to question number 43 Brian I did
check but nagas was definitely first I
assure you well Tom is winning right now
Brian Brian is second and the third
place is shared between button although
I don't think button is playing anymore
and Alden Sola then we have Gerardo and
Naga SH and after that we have oh no and
we have a third sub with three correct
answers and then we have a couple of
players would only one answer so let's
go to question number 43 button is here
but he's not trying to answer
yeah I'm sorry button yeah Adam because
well most points to go to Tom Smith and
Bryant so if you if you make the effort
you can still make it now for the most
important question of the quiz well
almost
you I want all of you to know this one
normos sobre no me answers first very
nice no my super normal if there is how
it is pronounced this is your first plus
in my book so congratulations on that
and yes the magician from Riga is
Michael Tao yes yours Arabs comments are
always hilarious yes the best attacker
of all time okay let's check question
number 44 okay no spamming guys only
answers in the chat
[Music]
okay I have to check this one because
you all started typing and we have a lot
of answers with 14 but the first correct
answer is Brian with 15 so Brian gets
the plus and now unfortunately it's not
13 it's 15 you're you're welcome to
check it out so congratulations to Brian
for this very nice answer okay
Allen just for you I will check it again
but you will see that I was correct
okay first Goran Matic answered 21 then
Tom Smith answered 14 then algún
answered 14 then no mr. Burnham answered
14 then some chess player to win 2099
answered that was my favorite player and
then Brian answered 15 and Allen you are
after Brian but you answered incorrectly
answered 13 Brian tongue I don't know
who he is but he is doing quite well
ah okay that's no problem
well question number 45 now if you play
chess online then you should know this
one
Tom Smith is first an album than Brian
and yes it is Hikaru Nakamura also known
as the bullet demon and I have a
question here I have an answer here by
Peter Varma who answered Hanson and yeah
Hanson Hanson could be considered the
bullet demon but he is still far too
weak well to face Nakamura in a bullet
match you had naka with you have
breakfast with naka and Florida that's
that's quite an honor I hope it was a
good breakfast okay let's go question
number 46
no my sovereign oh man he joined late
but he answered correctly
so congratulations no mr. burr no me
this is your second correct answer very
nice you get plus well you see there are
a lot of incorrect answers so you know
it's it's not that easy of a question
you're welcome no me let's go to
question number 47 now I'm sure everyone
knows this one but you never know
yes very nice it's Tom dan brian dean
peter then Zeppelin it is definitely
don't bring your queen out too early the
famous saying for players who love to
you know put their queen out too early
well not really late there are some
games played by Murphy where he never
even touched his Queen and one with a
brilliant
I want a brilliant game yes this is a
really very nice I like the answers well
except if you're playing bullets then
you definitely want to put your queen
out early so let's go question number 48
now I definitely would like all of you
to know this one
it's a very nice part of chess history
Tom Smith then no maiden Peter then
Brian yes it is Paul Morphy and after
this stream all of you will know that
his middle name is Paul Charles Murphy
Fisher versus sparkly no it's not Fisher
versus sparkly yes the Duke and his
council let's go to question number 48
yeah it's a very nice Murphy game
although it's so so common that well
everybody knows it and there are a lot
of our games by Murphy that are just as
nice a series on a game on games where
the Queen doesn't move yeah that would
be quite a series I will consider it
okay question number 49 it's a very nice
question so some of you may know the
answer no it's not Kuryakin you can't
answer karaoke non every question and
I'll Doon berry nice Auden
Alden Sola answers correctly for his
fifth correct correct answer yes it is
definitely France Francois Andre Daniken
Philidor very nice guys no it's not mom
oh and we have an answer by Jason Lutz
Anna and I'm glad that someone knows who
it's Anna was Philip or okay guys
question number 50 Wow the Enzo you've
been here since I've been 3 K that's a
lot of time thanks a lot man
let's go question number 50 and in here
I only need the name of the winner of
course
and Tom Smith answers first which is
correct intelligent species did answer
first although he answered it before the
question even appeared so he answered it
spamming the last question so this does
go to Tom Smith and I hope you I hope
you know this game yes it's Fischer
Bayern yeah I only need it's not it's
not it's not that hard of a quiz to be
requesting the other guy's name is F and
you want half a point for Donald Bayern
well ok I will give you half a point for
Donald barn if you tell me Donald barns
brother's name
so I dare you there
yes yes it's Robert barn Fischer had a
very nice time beating both of them up
yeah well even if you google it you'll
still remember it yes Donald and Robert
Byron very nice guys lost a lot of games
to Fischer yes Oscar I'm in Croatia but
let's go to question number 51 and this
is a very nice question
and now still not you way and I'll do an
answers first and not a lot of people
know this Bryan second Oscar third so
algún congratulations you do get a point
here very nice
and yes Michael Tao did beat Mikhail
Botvinnik and although he only held the
title for a year one of the things well
there are there are 64 people playing
now so if you know I don't know if you
know who Rasheed Najma Tino was he was
tells a good friend and a second of his
in his match against Botvinnik and you
should search on youtube for Jessica
Fischer and watch her documentary on
Rasheed Najma Tino it's one of the
greatest videos I've ever seen so if you
like towel you will like Rasheed and you
will definitely like this video meadow
is here Mary's chilling he's waiting for
this quiz to end and then he will go for
a walk so let's go to question number 52
Yanni's matino versus towel is the best
game the Michael Tao said himself that
it's the best game he ever lost
Najma Tino was not his trainer Alexandre
Coblentz was his trainer and asthma Tino
was just well not just but he was his
second and he didn't crush tall with his
style it was Rasheed style as well but
it okay let's go to question number 52
yeah okay
yes yes it's the same question so we
will skip this one
I checked all of the questions but it
seems the one slipped away so we are
going to skip this one question number
three 53 yes yes it's a repeat ESS so
let's go question number 53 let's see
who knows this one yes it happens I
didn't have a lot of time to plan this
okay who knows this one Wow
acid the forgot and acid the four
answers first the FIR the correct answer
is Kuryakin although I'm pretty sure you
answer car racking to all of my
questions but still I do have to give
you a point for this one so yeah in 2016
in Doha Qatar surgery car can won the
world blitz championship very nice yes
in the acid of admits that that was 100%
luck but still I have to give him a
point so that's that let's go to
question number 54
yes Carson is first with boots rating
although I think ding Liron ding Liron
is now first in blitz rating but I will
have to check that one so let's go
question number 54
a lagoon very nice Alan Alden is a beast
guys so out on answers correctly no it's
not made or unfortunately I like the
answer but it's not metal its Vasily
eventually and Alden answers first very
nice and no it's not NACA yeah III know
the gross get broadcaster doesn't like
to be in Norway and they even had a
special camera that was recording only
magnus carlsen well but he didn't win
anything
and he was the vastly van choking blitz
and rapid so that's how charkie rolls so
let's go to question number 55 and I'm
pretty sure none of you know this one
but I could be wrong
no it's not Carlson nor on or Fisher nor
Karpov no one answered correctly so far
ah
Danzo Shimura very nice Danzo Shimura
dance of shamora gets his first plus in
my book it is William Stein it and not
only did a claim to have defeated a God
at chess but he said that he also could
give give him a upon handicap because it
wasn't interesting to play with God you
know without a handicap but yeah very
nice Danzo so it also seems like a hard
question ok let's go to a question
number well know Fischer would probably
say that he could give him a nice
handicap but where where the duck is
stone tom is Tom is killing somewhere
question number 56
and be careful what you write at this
one
and pedro mateo answers first
very nice Pedro material get a plus it's
not the blue guises deep thought yeah
one the computer gary played before deep
blue so it's not the blue it's deep
thought it's the first computer that was
able to defeat a grandmaster at chess
but very nice very nice answers yeah I
mean you did say only deep although that
could mean a lot of things yeah it's the
one that isn't famous yeah although it
should be I mean it's the first computer
to ever beat a grandmaster at the game
I'm from Croatia Demetria thank you for
asking
ok so let's go for another question
question number 57 and I'm pretty sure
everyone knows this vinai Gangji maybe I
don't know yeah it's quite a summer in
Croatia ok who knows this now it's not
Fisher and Bryan answers first very nice
so Bryan can speak Persian and checkmate
comes from Persian chat mat which does
mean the king is dead so very nice here
is a plus for you yes yes the king is
dead very nice guys very nice I like it
French jr. that would be the answer
maybe to the previous question so that's
quite a pink ok guys let's get ready for
question number 58 hope you're ready ok
okay this is now this is not cool at all
so the this question has repeated itself
so we'll just skip this one yeah we
already had that one yes it is deep
thought yeah yeah so skipping on to the
next question question number 59
[Music]
okay you typed very fast so I will just
have to check the chat for this one who
was first okay I don't see any correct
answer so far okay Bryan Bryan is close
okay
and yeah Bryan also gave another answer
but no one gave a correct answer before
him so yes
Bryan you are correct the longest chess
game ever played was 269 moves between
nickel each and our sewage in Belgrade
in 1989
so very nice Bryan gets plus I'm pretty
sure all of you were googling this one
so but if if you weren't then very nice
and for question number 60 let's hope it
doesn't repeat itself so question number
60 is here what is here and let's see if
you know this one this is the hardest
question of the quiz
and Alden enters first and Gordon Martic
enter second and Tom answers third so
all them very nice here you will get
another plus and yeah definitely it's
Mike hotel very nicely done
and let's just since this is the last
question we will count the points so
it's
so tom is first with 21 correct answers
now second is either brown or Alden but
I have to check so Brian is 10 correct
answers and algún is 8 correct answers
so Thomas first with 21 points
Brian tank is second with 10 points and
Alden Sola is third with 8 points and
button Oscar had a nice run but he well
he gave up because of his large ping so
yeah
congratulations Tom I mean sure you
might have the fastest internet but you
also know your chest so very nicely done
and also to Brian and also to know me to
album solo very nice guys so like I said
the and I just want to show you this
would be the the elimination round if we
had a tie so this would be the question
for the elimination round let's see if
any of you would know it
so who knows this
yes yes it's definitely cool you found
very nice as you all know this and I
like the answer from vist called Aria a
polgár and Judit Polgar was even higher
rated than that but as she retired from
professional chess as a player she's no
longer ranked as number one women player
so congratulations tom you will send me
your your address and where you would
like to receive this set here we will
show the set one once again as it's a
very nice set and I wish I had one of
those women will play man very soon I'm
sure
so this is the set like I said it's it's
all wooden board it's a fountain design
for the pieces it's 46 by 46 centimeters
and well it's I think it's about the
size of a regular Olympic chess board so
I'm sure you all will have a lot of fun
playing with this the next quiz I don't
know probably in a month maybe well in a
month surely not before that so all of
you guys better get faster internet ah
Thomas from Slovenia very nice yes yes
Vienna GOG next time it will be just
walk but who knows maybe it will be both
maybe it will be the clock and the set
yes I will try to modify it either make
the questions harder or something you
know so all the players can have a
chance in winning this so yeah that's it
once more congratulations to Tom you're
welcome to contact me I when I post this
video I will put well you can also just
send it to agamotto on gmail or on
google or on skype or on facebook or
anywhere you'd like I will know it's you
so so you are able to receive the set
I guess the move would be too hard I
think and could be could take pretty
long by Zeppelin I'm very glad you you
you lasted till till the end well the
next quiz like I said will be in about a
month but I'll definitely let you know
in some of my videos very nice well okay
thank you all for watching I had a great
time like I said I love chess and I'll
have a good quiz and to all of you who
participated and especially to Brian and
Alden who were 2nd and 3rd place I
congratulate you all as well yeah thank
you all guys you were great and maybe
next time some of you will win a chess
or a chess clock and most of all I hope
you learned something and and yeah
that's it so see you soon bye for now
and this is the end of the stream
[Music]